was there something about your
girlfriend at the time was pregnant and
then after the sighting she became not
pregnant and it was because of alien
interference i don't know if i'm reading
that from by surmising from the
questions or if i've read or heard that
somewhere
well boy that is something i i don't
really bring out that much because you
know
uh
she works in a
government facility and um
you know has a security clearance and uh
um i really don't have her permission to
talk about that or name her or whatever
but yeah
um
she had a mark across her stomach i went
into the
gynecologist's office with her i
observed on the ultrasound
that
there was a placenta a cord
and the
fetus said just disappear
why do you think that is
i don't know
um
the one speculation of is obviously that
uh
the the baby was taken by you know some
alien technology another alternative uh
is uh medically speaking
some kind of a thing where they claim
that a baby can be reabsorbed but if
that were really true you would think it
would affect the cord and a placenta too
but
it didn't
i know that you have intuitions or
feelings that these
beings were being helpful toward you
given that do you think yes
i'm wondering
i think
go ahead i'm just wondering okay
how is the removal of a fetus
positive unless
maybe the baby would have been born
cancerous or
have some other issue so i'm curious if
you don't mind
i'm sure you've thought about this do
you mind letting us know your
speculations well uh obviously the
theory is uh you know that uh
we conjecture that the baby is alive
somewhere it was just taken
uh for a more
nurturing
environment
uh with really super super high tech i
guess uh the woman's body is not
absolutely necessary
um that's the theory how far along was
she in the pregnancy
um
i i
in days i i don't know
i i don't have that on the tip of my
tongue
was it within a month or was it within
six months
plus or minus a month or you have no
record oh it wasn't a
very large uh
amount of development you know
loose clothing she probably could have
disguised the fact that she was pregnant
do you regret that the abduction
happened do you wish it didn't
absolutely oh i wish
i wish i'd never gotten out of that
truck
just
not not a big positive in my life
or even in those
that i care about
not positive with respect to the press
and the accusations or
or the ptsd or what
all of the above including just that uh
the topic never escapes you know
it's
just to live a normal life react to
normal things be interested in things
it's even hard to be
under the weather now
under the radar
what i mean was
that to be recognized everywhere you go
is
some people think would be pretty cool
but uh
not really do people come up and try to
take pictures with you
all the time
i get people to knock on my door
hello i'm in town
i know you live here
could i trouble you for
an autograph and a picture
is this okay so right now i'm sure
you're considered
your identity is the ufo person at least
as far as other people are concerned is
there something else you'd like to be
known for
do you have another hobby no just
uh
dad grandpa
[Laughter]
uh something other than that guy